going to turn out of the Middle East
where Israel and militants in Gaza have
been bombarding each other now for three
straight days other countries trying to
broker a ceasefire but so far no luck
and there is already considerable damage
from strikes by Israeli warplanes inside
Gaza and Islamic Jihad rockets inside
Israel Ian Lee has more
Sirens Blair across Southern Israel
overnight as Rockets from Gaza streak
across the sky Palestinian militants
have fired more than 500 in the past
four days Israel has intercepted many
but not all yesterday one rocket hit an
apartment building killing an Israeli
man and wounding five others another
destroyed Miriam Karen's house she asked
who knows what the future holds for us I
survived today and that's what matters
in Gaza the suffering also continues
Israel hit roughly 150 targets
Palestinian officials say more than 30
people have been killed including at
least 10 civilians in the current
fighting this father carries the
lifeless body of his ten-year-old
daughter one of the youngest victims
parents there worry for their children
Hindi says we don't feel safe even at
home
the worst fighting in months escalated
after Israel targeted key commanders of
Islamic Jihad in Gaza Israel's prime
minister warned his country will kill
whoever threatens it Egyptian mediators
are now working for a ceasefire the
question isn't if they'll succeed but
rather when they do how long it will
last for CBS morning's Ian Lee in London